look at this kitchen counter so clean
this one not so much
the first may seem safer but both could
be harboring their coronavirus there's a
common misconception between cleaning
and disinfection that's Brian were
shocked he's the general manager of the
Kovach 19 response team for aftermath
surfaces anybody without training can
clean it's gonna be everything that you
can't see that needs to be disinfected
he's gonna explain how to properly and
safely disinfect your home at a bare
minimum you're gonna want to have gloves
and potentially a paper mask and goggles
when you're preparing to disinfect
you're going to need towels whether it
be paper towels or drop cloths or
whatever that you have to wipe the
surfaces you're going to need to have
some sort of disinfectant you're gonna
want to assure that that disinfectant is
on the EPA's list that specifically
kills the coronavirus if you can't find
any disinfectants in the store you can
make a bleach mixture at home using 1/3
cup to a gallon of water or 4 teaspoons
to a quart of water when working with
bleach make sure that you're in a
well-ventilated area and wearing the
proper PPE step 1 is going to be
identifying the surfaces that you're
going to disinfect so you're gonna pick
out your high touch areas whether it be
your light switches faucets doorknobs
things that you know for sure you're
gonna touch things that you wouldn't
even think twice you know when you touch
it on normal circumstances but you're
gonna have to really have heightened
senses of what you touch on a regular
basis and even outside of the home there
are certain services that you probably
are gonna want to disinfect your
exterior doorknobs your mailbox the
handle to your vehicle things like that
that you wouldn't normally think would
be high touch but you do touch them
everything
step two is going to be preparing the
surface for disinfection you're gonna do
this by using the towels that you have
available with warm water or warm soapy
water you're gonna wipe down all of the
surfaces that you are going to be
disinfecting to remove any surface gross
filth dust debris whatever it may be
now that you've cleaned the surfaces
they may appear clean they may appear
that there's nothing there but it's
gonna be what you can't see the
microscopic bacteria microbials
viruses that you can't see that you have
now prepared the surface for the
disinfectant to work on step three is
disinfect your services now that your
surfaces are ready to disinfect you're
gonna want to down whatever PPE that you
do have available gloves masks and
goggles would be best for starters then
once you have on your PPE and you're
ready you're gonna apply the
disinfectant if your disinfectant is
coming through a spray bottle you're
gonna want to mist it onto the surfaces
you're gonna want to make sure that you
are not saturating or leaving pooling
behind you need to disinfect it to do
its job and it needs to be mist it onto
the surface and stay damp for the
allotted cure time if you have a wipe
you're gonna want to remove it from the
container that it's in apply it to the
surfaces by wiping back and forth across
the surface you're gonna use that wipe
until it starts to dry up and it's no
longer leaving any disinfectant behind
step four is wait you're waiting for the
disinfectant to do its job it varies by
disinfectant some can be as soon as
instantaneous and some can be up to ten
minutes always refer to the label that's
on the bottle or refer to the CDC's of
recommendations for how long to let it
cure the step five is going to be to
rinse the surfaces the best practice is
going to be to fold a kitchen towel into
fourths damp that towel and then use one
side of it to do one sweeping motion
open it up use the other side of it that
way you're getting the most out of that
towel when you're rinsing the surfaces
it's best practice that each swipe is
about five to eight feet if you're using
paper towels one towel folded in half
should cover the same five to eight feet
after this the surfaces will air dry or
you can dry them by hand with another
paper towel or
that's how you have available after you
are completely done with disinfecting
you should probably repeat the process
depending on your lifestyle if you're
headed out of the home several times a
day you're going to want to do it
several times a day if you work from
home twice three times a day should
suffice it should be in the morning
afternoon and evening though I think
when people are getting comfortable in
their homes they're getting complacent
and they're not thinking that they have
to disinfect surfaces but you know you
truly don't understand who has the virus
because they could be asymptomatic so
you do need to take the extra precaution
regardless of what the surface may look
like already
[Music]